foreign
that's fine
I need the microphone
yeah so you can have a seat that's fine
microphone
maybe you can just talk real loud for me
oh hold on just a minute I really can't
hear you
foreign
okay oh you have you have a problem with
a hernia yes okay and it's it's really
really important where you can't
concentrate
nice to this I don't know why he
bothered me too much I know but what I
want to make sure you understand if I
excuse you today I'm excusing you from
the jury I'm trying to go today home and
take medicine and rest ready for
tomorrow okay I can't do that I I can't
I can't have that done we have to keep
going so I mean has it been bothering
you other days in the while you've been
on the jury no today you start now never
a bother more than one two weeks okay
but it might bother you also tomorrow
I'm not sure but I'm trying to do my
best to I know you're trying to do your
best but I want to make sure you're
healthy too I don't want you to to ruin
your health for this all right just sit
there for a second if I can have the
attorneys do you have any
all right sir we just want to make sure
you're healthy and everything so we're
going to excuse you from this jury okay
all right just take care of yourself
okay all right thank you
foreign
thank you
we'll do it later
all right yes ma'am do you have
something before the jury comes in
okay which one
548
perfect okay
all right
okay 548 is done all right I did have
one question
um there seems to be a few oh you can
that's okay you can stay there we don't
have the jury here uh there seems to be
a few
uh exhibits I just want to make sure of
um you gave us we have everything that
you just gave us earlier from Dr
Kipper's deposition but I just want to
make sure if there were redactions
needed for 395 or 414 or am I using
mine for that
I just want to see
I mean I can just give you the numbers
the ones I'm not sure about and you can
look at it and we can move on I just 405
455
304
307
395 and 414. I'm just not sure if those
I'm waiting for redactions or if I'm
using the ones I'm going to use
and then you had one that uh I'm not
sure if you said 1083 or 283
. so if you could let me know I I heard
1083 as the exhibit number
Jamie heard 283 so I just want to make
sure we get the right one
that was with Dr kippers you said 1063
then you said
either 1083 or 283 and I'm not sure
which
you can get back to me on it Mr
nadelhoff I don't want to catch you off
guard
three or four
455.
405. oh there you go
283 Jamie's always right that's good
good to know okay all right if you want
to hand those up that'd be fantastic
all right is there anything else before
the jury comes yes your honor just for
the record
um plaintiff's exhibit for uh 47
plaintiff's exhibit 48 and plaintiff's
exhibit 41 were also
um used and offered during Kipper but I
Dr Kipper's deposition I believe I
passed the redactive versions of those
up to you yes we have all of those okay
thank you
I think that
should be everything if not we'll we'll
get back with you okay thank you
all right
okay are you ready for the jury then all
right thank you
okay
thank you ladies and gentlemen just to
let you know juror 25 was experiencing
some health issues and obviously your
health is a top priority for us so I
went ahead and excused him for the jury
and that's why we have alternates so
okay all right all right thank you
all right we can continue
with Miss Lloyd's testimony
where it says this attractive therapy
will
include therapy personal Psychotherapy
and couples therapy with his fiancee
Amber both are in agreement to this plan
yes
um do you recall that couple's therapy
was a component of Mr depth treatment
I don't recall what was that between him
and the doctor
you recall Mr death and Miss heard
attending couples therapy together
if we could turn to the next page here
and then at the top it says I met with
Amber for 90 minutes and discussed the
above and her concerns that he be
strictly monitored and supervised
um
do you recall
Dr Kipper meeting with with Amber early
on in Mr Duff's treatment
I do not
if we could bring back up
um
document the
which is now marked as a civil YouTube
is that correct
23 23 oh
um
can we please go to the entry for June
24th
2014 which is on Deck 1661.
okay
now
um
with respect to the entry for June 24
2014. this is a no this is an entry you
prepared correct correct
and the first line says RN and we met
with patients Beyonce to inform her a
treatment plan for patient do you see
that I do
um does this refresh your recollection
that you attended a meeting with Dr
Kipper and miss her concerning Mr Deb's
treatment
I don't recall the meeting
do you have any reason to doubt that
this meeting occurred yeah
do you have any
um other than what's reflected in this
note do you have any other independent
recollection of any such meeting with Dr
Tipper and the third I do not
um if I could direct your attention just
to the last line of the note
it says here
um
she was encouraged to call RN or MD with
any questions or concerns that might
arise do you see that I do
um
throughout your treatment of Mr depth
did Miss heard reach out to you with
questions and concerns
yes
she had your phone number correct yes
and I think we saw some text messages
but Mr nadelhoff was asking a question
where she misheard was reaching out to
you correct correct
um
when Mr Depp became your patient did
Miss heard ever show you any pictures of
Mr death
I don't recall
do you recall Miss heard showing you any
pictures of cocaine
I don't recall
do you recall Miss heard ever showing
you any audio recordings of Mr Jeff
I don't recall
um
okay I'd like to move on to the um
Mr that's detox and that was on his
private island correct
correct
um
and
you travel you traveled down to the
island with Mr Depp is that right
I don't recall
I'd have to if it should be in my notes
go
um we can look at those in a moment
um but you you were on the island with
Mr Depp for the
majority of his detox correct yes
and when you um we're on the island did
you see where Mr Depp was staying yes
and um with misheard staying with him in
that location as well
yes and what did their accommodations
look like
can you be more specific
what what type of structure were they
staying in it was a house
um we pull up
um document e which is a short video
standby
and for the record this was produced as
depth 9811
during exhibit 25.
let me know whenever you need me to play
Council uh please play thank you
uh Miss Floyd do you recognize the
location reflected in that video yes and
uh what is it it's the Chinese
homeowners Island
and is that where he was staying during
the detox process yes
is is that video consistent with how the
house looked in in August of 2014. yes
okay
um
is there any part of the house that's
not reflected in that video
the bathroom wasn't in the video
when you were on the island where you
were personally overseeing Mr Deb's
detox process correct correct
and how often would you
um see him in person
during that that's an answer
it varied
did you see him in person at least once
a day
I cannot recall
when Dr Kipper arrived do you recall how
often he would see Mr death
I do not
what substances was Mr dot excuse me
what substances was Mr depth detoxing
from
opiate
is he detoxing from any other substances
not on the uh no I don't recall
um
have you overseen other patients detox
detoxing from opiate before you were
caring for Mr death yes
how many would you estimate
100
hundreds
what's it what is that process
and what does that process do to the
person physically
they go through withdrawal symptoms and
we medicate them
and what type of withdrawal symptoms
have you observed
nausea vomiting body aches
high low erection
ronorrhea
restlessness
anxiety
is there a time during the detox process
when those symptoms are particularly the
most acute
yeah what what stage in the process is
that typically day three through five or
six
how would you describe Mr Depp's
physical state throughout the detox
process
I don't recall specifics I'd have to
refer to my notes
how would you describe Mr Depp's
psychological Faith throughout the detox
process
I don't recall I have to review my notes
um all right let's go back to your notes
then which I believe is
um exhibit 23.
um could we first go to the entry dated
August 8th 2014.
foreign
Miss Floyd does this refresh your
recollection as to when you arrived on
the island to assist Mr Death In His
detox process
according to my notes it was August 8th
and so as I think we established earlier
you met Mr Depp in in June
um fair to say that you had known him
for about two months at this time
correct okay
um
can we please go to the entry for August
11 2014.
okay
um and this is a note you prepared
yes okay
um
if you need to take a minute and read it
over
um just let me know when you're done or
I can
go right into it
okay
um
fair to say that this note reflects that
Mr Depp was experiencing
discomfort on this date
according to my notes yes
it says he was experiencing muscle
spasms chills and pains right correct
did you
um personally observe
Mr death in this state
um according to this note it does not
appear I did
um are these symptoms typical during a
detox process yes they are
um can we please go to the entry for
August 12 2014.
um and I believe we look you looked at
this earlier but I just like to draft
direct your attention to the last line
in this first paragraph and be arriving
this morning and we'll assess patients
do you see that
where are we on what so I directed your
attention to the
um August 12 2014 entry and yes yes
sorry
um
and so
based on your note it appears that Dr
Kipper arrived on the island on August
12th is that correct correct okay
um was the plan always for Dr Kipper to
come down to the island to attend to Mr
Depp
I don't recall
um do you recall any issues in your
caring for Mr Depp prior to Dr Kipper's
arrival
do you recall any medical issues arising
with Mr Depp before Dr Kipper arrived
that caused you concern
I don't recall
um
if there had been a
serious medical issue with Mr death
prior to Dr Kipper's arrival would that
have been reflected in your notes yes
if Mr Debb's Behavior had been
unmanageable prior to Dr Skipper's
arrival would that have been
um
can we please go to the next entry for
August 13th
um and Miss Lloyd this is also a note
that you prepared
oh now I'd like to direct your attention
to the portion of the note that starts
with 1340.
again this is military time is that
right correct
and I think you testified earlier this
is the time that you prepared the note
not the
time of the events reflect in the note
is that right
yes
sometimes I mean I I don't recall
specifics but sometimes they were
at times and sometimes they were done
later
so generally speaking when you prepare
these nursing notes
um
how long after the events reflected in
the note was the note actually prepared
by you it varied okay
okay so directing your attention back to
the portion that starts with 1348.
um do you see where it says patience
fiance Texas say he's it wasn't feeling
well
MD orders Vino
64.8 milligrams Neurontin 600 milligrams
that patient and fiance informed that
today and tomorrow will be the most
difficult days and to keep in close
contact with us you do that yes
do you recall informing Mr Depp and
misheard that the following days would
be the most difficult
just what was stated in my notes
can we please go to the entry for
August 17 2014
do you see that I do and this is a note
you've prepared correct
um
do you recall this specific event
I do not
do you have any reason to doubt that
what is reflected in your Note is
accurate
no
so when you wrote
um RN and MD found patients sitting
quietly on his board
you believe that's an accurate
recitation of how you found Mr death on
this date correct when you wrote that he
was calm and stated he was frustrated
probably
you have no reason to doubt the accuracy
of that statement
correct
because we could we bring back up
um exhibit 23 and specifically go to
the August 18 2014 entry which is on
depth 1677.
um
Miss Lloyd I'd like to direct your
attention to
um
well first of all this is a note that
you prepared correct correct okay and
I'd like to direct your attention to the
end of the note which is actually on the
second page or the next page
um do you see at the end here where it
says patient was escorted back exported
to bed do you see that yes
um would that have been you who afforded
Mr debb to bed
I don't recall
um you testified earlier though that you
did
um see Mr Death In His the home that he
was staying in on the island correct
correct
um and it says planners to leave the
island tomorrow
I do
and directing your attention to the next
note August 19th do you see that it says
um next to 2335 arrived back in LA
yes okay so
um
does this accurate or really excuse me
because accurately reflect that
um
you left the island on August 19 2014.
according to these notes yes
um
I'd like to direct your attention to
um
the August 20th 2014 entry which starts
on the next page
and then if you go to the next page as
well you can see that there's another
entry for August 20th 2014. do you see
that oh yeah yeah okay
um on on this page here I'd like to
direct your attention to the portion
that starts with 12 30. do you see that
yes
um now it says here RN and MB spent time
talking with patient do you see that I
do
um
this would have been you and Dr Kipper
correct correct and does this reflect
that you spoke with Mr Depp in person
I don't recall I would yes
okay and um the rest the note goes on to
say patient Express frustration with the
detox process and with not liking how
the phenobarb was making him feel
initially he stated he was done with the
process and no longer wanted MD and RN
services
after processing his feelings and
realizing how far he had come
and that part of his wanting to give up
was due to tensions between him and his
fiance patient fiance Aaron and MD came
up with a plan for fiance to take a few
days for herself
patient was willing to continue
treatment but was going to refuse
phenobarbital from this point forward do
you see that I do
okay did I read that correctly
um
do you recall
tensions between Mr Depp and misheard at
this stage in his detox process
yes and what do you recall about that
I would call Johnny feeling that she was
trying to interfere
um
in what way did he feel she was trying
to interfere
by reporting to us things that he didn't
feel were true
can you think of a specific instance
where Miss heard reported something to
you that was you found out later was not
true
I can't I cannot remember specifics
um
do you recall the plan for Miss heard to
take a few days for herself
it's all specifics
but you do recall that there being
tension between Mr Depp and misheard
around this time
yes and
you recall that having an impact on Mr
Depp's treatment
I don't recall specifics
let's go on to the entry for August 25th
please
um
first of all is this an over you've
prepared
it is
um directing your attention to the
portion that starts with 1900.
um first line says meeting at MD's house
was quite stressful for patient you see
that I do
you recall attending a meeting with Mr
death at Dr Kipper's house
I don't recall
the next line says him and his fiance
are having a hard time communicating and
understanding each other's point of view
and feelings do you see that
you do
um do you recall any specifics about
this situation I do not
um
a couple sentences down it says plan is
for fiancee to start therapy tomorrow do
you see that
yes
um do you recall that misheard um
started therapy shortly after
Mr Depp's detox process
I don't recall
do you have any understanding as to why
Miss heard was starting therapy
I do not
uh directing your attention to the entry
for August 27th
2014 which starts on depth one six feet
seven or eight six excuse me
168 times yep
um again this is an entry you've
prepared
it is
um okay do you see where it says receive
text from patient's sister that patient
had been recording music with his friend
until five
and did not go to sleep until seven and
is currently sleeping
yes
and who is um
their deaf sister
referred to here
Christy
and at this time that you met Christy
before
I don't recall
have you met Christy before
yeah how many times
I don't know
more than once more than once yes
uh
at this time had you communicated with
Christy about Mr Debb's treatment before
I don't recall
um okay the entry goes on to say sister
stated that patient and his fiancee had
had a disagreement last night and that
patient was able to remain calm and
handle the situation appropriately do
you see that yeah
um
do you recall Miss uh do you recall
Christy telling you that I do not see
the portion of the note that starts with
13 30.
I do
um the second line reads
patient expressing feeling about
argument with fiance and field
relationship and putting unwanted stress
on him right now do you see that did you
um do you recall this exchange with Mr
Depp
sorry I didn't catch that flight I'm
sorry I did not okay
um based on this node do you can you
tell whether this was a conversation you
had in person with Mr Depp
based on this note
yes
um do you recall on other occasions Mr
debb expressing to you that his
relationship was putting unwanted stress
on him
I'd have to review my notes
um okay directing your attention down to
the portion of the note that says that
starts with 21 30.
um it says patient back home for patient
he has a long he had a long conversation
with fiance and they both understand
that right now is a time to work on
themselves as individuals patient's
fiance now has an RN
to help for anxiety and to monitor her
while she's starting a new youth
stabilizer medication
you do
um who
I believe you testified to this earlier
Miss heard's
um nurse was was Erin forum is that
right
and
Miss Borum was an employee of yours is
that correct she was an independent
contractor okay
um but you you placed her
Dr Kipper is that right
okay
um
do you recall When Miss
um Forum was assigned misheard
I do not recall
do you have any understanding as to why
um Miss heard needed a nurse
other than what my notes State I do not
do you recall witnessing
um misheard being anxious or having
anxiety
I do not recall
um now the last line here says patient
feels this will take some of the stress
off their relationship
and in return if we could go to the next
page take some stress off of him
diary that correctly
um
do you recall why Mr Depp felt that Ms
heard having a nurse would
reduce the stress on their relationship
I do not recall
[Music]
from your perspective was it important
to Mr Depp
treatment that his stress be reduced
best
and why is that
any patient going through
detox or changes
always important to relieve as much
stress as you can from them
um let's go to the entry for September
10th please which is on depth 1694 and
continues on to 1695
September 10 2014 entry this is your
entry for have you prepared this all
right sorry sorry and
um if I could direct your attention to
the portion that starts with two three
three zero which is actually on the next
page
um
the first line says that was patient he
complained of body aches and nausea do
you see that I do
um and does this reflect that you were
physically with Mr death at this time
it would yes okay
um a couple sentences down it says and
this portion is is highlighted here
while RN was visiting patient Beyonce
came in and tried to start argument with
him patient was able to stay calm and
talk his fiancee down can you see that
I do
um
do you recall the incident reflected in
this note
we do not
do you recall any instances where you
witnessed misheard
um try to start a fight with Mr Depp
how many instances do you remember
I don't recall specific numbers
you remember at least one
yes do you remember more than one
yeah
more than two
I don't recall specific numbers
um
what uh
what do you remember about that first
instance that you can remember
I remember one night trying to leave the
penthouse and Amber standing in the
elevator and not letting us leave
uh why wasn't she letting you leave I I
she didn't want him to leave
had they been fighting previous to that
point
I wasn't there previously
and what's the other instance you
remember
I can't remember specifics
um
you have any reason to doubt the
accuracy of what's reflected in your
note here
no
do you have any understanding as to what
you meant when you said patient was able
to remain calm was able to stay calm
excuse me and talk his fiancee down
I don't recall the events of that note
have you seen Mr Depp and Miss heard get
in a fight before this date
I don't know let's go to the entry for
September 12th please
okay
and this is a note that you prepared as
well miss Floyd is correct okay
um
the first line here says RN and MD
visited patient at work do you see that
you do
um and so
this reflects that both you and Dr
Kipper went and saw Mr death is that
right
correct
um and the entry States here
patient expressed some concerns with
Beyonce's behavior and how it is adding
stress to his life do you see that I do
um do you recall this
Mr dupp saying this to you in this
instance I do not
um
do you have any reason to doubt the
accuracy of what's reflected in your
note and do not
um could we please go to the entry for
October 22nd 2014 which starts on
uh one seven one seven and continues on
to depth one seven one eight
my notes are different what's the top of
the
let me see the top of that just so I
know what I'm looking
okay oh
um
first of all this is also a note that
you prepared correct correct
um
and if you want to take a minute and
read through the note I know it
goes on first two patients
okay
just let me know when you
've read through it
okay
um
fair to say that this note reflects that
you and Mr in Georgia this when this
the events in this note occurred
I think we were
at the end it says now in Georgia
that I would I I don't recall but it the
travel day well do you see above that
where it says 10 22 and then below it it
says now in Georgia yeah okay
um So based on your notes you were in
Georgia on October 22nd 2019
um
do you recall being in Georgia with Mr
death
yes
um do you recall who else was with you
in Georgia
I don't recall who was with us but I the
the purpose of the trip was to visit
Amber on location
okay so so Amber was in Georgia as well
yes
um now directing your attention to the
portion of the entry which is on the
next page and begins with 15 30.
um
it speaks here
um
he requested an emergency session with
the psychiatrist to discuss feeling
about arguments with fiance and would
like some tools to help them
feel his
to help him deal with his emotions
do you see that did you
um do you recall Mr Depp and misheard
having a fight on this trip in Georgia
I do not do you recall who Mr dead
psychiatrist was at this time
I do not
do you recall why Mr Duff started seeing
a psychiatrist
I do not
um
directing your attention down to the
portion of the note that starts with
2010. it says here patients spoke to a
psychiatrist for 50 minutes and was open
and honest with his feelings
he feels better after conversation but
also feels he is in a no-win situation
with fiance do you see that
I I'm kind of lost where we're at right
now oh sorry okay yes yes yeah sorry
okay
um
does this reflect that you were present
with Mr Depp when he spoke to his
psychiatrist
I don't remember
it was based on him telling me or if I
was present
do you recall Mr Depp ever expressing to
you that he felt he was in a no-win
situation with her
I don't recall those specific words
um
but you you wrote them in your nursing
that's correct
um
you see at the bot so that
still in this portion that starts with
2010. do you see where it says uh
plan is for patient and fiance to go to
dinner this evening the patient is
feeling exhausted and wants to stay home
but does not want to upset fiance
we're on the same page yes we're still
in the portion of the note that starts
with 2010.
2018. okay yes yep
do you recall this specific incident
I do not
do you have any understanding as to why
Mr debb would be concerned about
upsetting his fiance
I do not
uh if we could go on to the next entry
which is on the same page uh 10 23.
um
and this is also a note you prepared
Miss Lloyd it is okay
um it says here you text patient to see
if RN could come by and check it do you
see that I did I do
um
why did you want to check in on
Instagram
I don't recall
were you ever concerned about Mr death
when he and Miss hard work in arguments
yes
why were you concerned
their arguments were a trigger for him
emotionally
any other reasons
no
what do you mean by a trigger for him
emotionally
they could cause him to be upset
add stress
um
the next portion of this note says when
Aaron arrived in the room patient was
agitated and felt fiance was using the
term Mania to express explain his
behavior and excuse herself from any
faltering arguments to do that
thank you
um do you have any
did you ever hear Miss heard use the
term Nadia to describe Mr Depp
I don't recall it that was I heard it
from her or heard it that she was saying
it to others
but you do have some recollection of
hearing that misheard was using that
word whether it was directly from her or
from others yes
um
the note goes on to say patient was
upset by this label
RN processes feelings with patients and
he was able to see fiance's negative
behavior did I read that correctly yes
um do you have any
uh recollection of what you you meant
when you wrote that
I do not
any understanding of what um fiance's
negative behaviors refers to
I don't recall specifics
do you recall generally
yes
and what do you recall
at times
she would
almost try to instigate him
and when you say see your referring to
miss her
um did you ever witness that personally
yes
um on more than one occasion
yes
ballpark how many times did you witness
that during their
ordering during the time you cared for
Mr death
I don't recall number
more than five
I don't recall
um when you say Miss heard would try to
instigate him what do you mean
I remember an argument or being in there
when he was going from room to room
trying to remove himself from a
situation and she would just follow him
from room to room and not give him his
space
and that's one specific incident
instance that you remember
yes
do you remember seeing that type of
behavior on other occasions
yes
um
are you aware of any of the fights that
we just
went through
um are you aware that any of them became
physical
no
um
from what you observed what was the
cause of
the friction between Mr death and Miss
Heart during this time I don't know
uh can we please go to the entry for
November 3rd 2014 which is on debt one
seven
one seven two sorry counselor
seven two one
um before this is also a note you
prepared
correct
um and it says here
you arrived at Mr Debb's home and he was
quote focused on relationship with
fiance and is struggling with conflicted
emotions did I read that right
yes
um
based on this note is that something Mr
death would have told you based on this
note it appears
so
um
looks like there's another note for
November 3rd below this one do you see
that
um and it continues on to the next page
which is one step one seven two two
if we could go there please
sound
and
and Miss boy directing your attention to
the portion that starts with one seven
zero zero
um do you see where it says RN when back
to patient's house he was chatting with
a friend and is feeling stressed about
his relationship do you see that I do
um and it goes on to say he feels she is
not being truthful with him and he is
not sure how to comfort her
about this when excuse me confront her
about this when she arrives home should
you see if you do you see that yes
um and the she here refers to miss heard
is that right
um do you remember this exchange with Mr
Depp
caption hearsay
um do you have any reason to doubt the
accuracy of your note I do not
if we could turn to the entry for
November 17 2014 which begins on depth
1723 which
um
it's like you see at the very bottom uh
it says 11 17 yes okay um and then I
think the entry itself is on the next
page
thank you
um this is also a note you prepared
correct
um and this says RN and MD went to
patients house to assess him do you see
that
um and so again this reflects uh that
you and Dr Kipper went to see Mr Depp
correct
um do you have any uh recollection of
why Mr or excuse me why Dr Kipper was
visiting with Mr death at this
I do not
um the next line says patient appeared
anxious and depressed over relationship
issues do you see that
I do
um
and then it says uh patient continues to
be ambivalent about relationship status
you see that I do
um do you recall Mr Depp expressing
these sentiments to you
objection hearsay
I don't recall specific conversations
but you also have but this is what you
wrote in your notes correct
I'm sorry I didn't catch that oh
correct sorry I'm sorry
um
do you recall when Mr death and misheard
got married
I don't recall the dates
but you said you testified earlier that
you did attend the wedding
correct
um
were you there to provide nursing
services
I don't really recall if I was a guest
or I I don't think they made that clear
to me
uh did Dr Tipper attend the wedding he
did and did Aaron Gorham attend the
wedding he did
do you recall any discussions of a
prenuptial agreement
um between Mr Def and misheard before
they got married yes
and what do you recall
I don't recall specifics
what you were called generally
I only recall what Johnny told me about
the conversation
and and what was that
that she didn't take it well
didn't take what well the idea
sorry I didn't hear the end of that the
idea of having to sign a prenup
did Johnny tell you that he asked miss
her to sign a prenup
I don't recall specifics
but you were called Johnny telling you
that Miss heard didn't want to fight
yes
and when you say it didn't take that
well what what are you referring to
from what Johnny said her reaction was
when he asked when they spoke about the
prenup
do you recall that in January of 2015
um Mr death and misheard traveled to
Japan together
I don't recall
do you recall traveling to Japan with Mr
duck
I recall being in Japan yes
and
do you remember anything specific about
that trip
I do not
do you recall Mr death and this hurt
having a fight on a plane
I recall a fight on a plane but I don't
know the time it was around
what do you remember about that fight
it was another instance where he was
sitting at a table and
thank you
not wanting to talk and she wouldn't
leave the table
what was she doing
she wouldn't leave the table
and he was saying you know please just
let just just go away
and what was she saying
I don't remember I don't remember her
words
how was her tone
I I don't recall
okay
um
you spoke with uh
Mr nadelhoff about this earlier but um
at some point you traveled to Australia
with Mr Depp right
can we pull up
um
what has been previously marked as
exhibit 14.
I'd like to direct your attention to the
March birth
2015 email from Dr Kipper at 2 10 p.m do
you see that I do
you recall
um Mr death having issues with his sleep
while when he was in Australia
not specifically in Australia
do you recall Mr debb having issues with
his sleep generally yes
and what issues were those
a hard time sleeping
and staying on a sleep schedule
Miss Lloyd when you were in Australia
with Mr Depp
um did you see where he was staying
yes and
how many times did you go to that
property
I don't recall specific numbers
um
fair to say you went there multiple
times though
yes
you talked about this with Mr nadelhoff
earlier at some point in Australia you
learned that Mr Depp had injured his
finger correct correct
and Dr Kipper was already in Australia
at that time
and
you testified earlier that
you and Dr Kipper went to see Mr Depp
after he injured his finger correct
correct
um
do you recall anything about this what
do you recall about Mr Depp's physical
appearance when you
don't recall specifics
what do you remember about his demeanor
if anything
I don't remember the events of when I
first arrived
but you did see Mr death at that time
correct
I can't recall when I initially saw him
after the finger event
and I believe you testified you don't
recall whether Miss heard was at the
house when you went to attend Mr death
correct correct
do you remember seeing miss heard in
Australia yeah
yeah did you ever see any injuries on
misheard when she was in Australia
yes
what did you see
a bruise on her arms
anything else
does she have any injuries to her face
that you can recall
not that I recall
any Cuts or abrasions that you can
recall
that I recall
um
do you recall Miss heard ever seeking
medical treatment from you well you
while she was in Australia
I do not recall her ever seeking a
medical treatment from me
uh
at the time that Mr death injured his
finger misheard was a patient of Dr
Kipper correct
I'm not sure
do you recall whether Miss Borum was
already
assigned to miss heard
I don't recall if she was working with
her at that time
um can we turn back to the nursing notes
which is exhibit 23.
specifically
tree for
um
March 7th which is on 1732.
in this March 7th of 2014 for uh this it
says 3 7 15. do you see that that's a
15. hold on
you said you saw a bruise on Miss
heard's arm at some point when you were
in Australia correct correct do you have
any understanding of how she got that
I do not
um
okay drafting your attention to
um the entry for March 7th 2015.
um you see here it says MD received text
message from client that he had been
arguing with his wife and that he cut
his finger
yes I see that okay so so this is the
date that um
you went and saw Mr Depp after his
injury correct
um now if I could direct your attention
down to the portion that starts with 15
30.
okay
um it says MD cleaned and dressed wound
to our middle finger do you see that
um
what does our middle finger reflect
right
and
so Mr Depp's had cut his middle right
finger is that correct
according to this yes
now if I could direct your attention
down to the bottom part of this entry
that starts with 11 30. you see that
I do
now this starts with patient and staff
returned from ER at
21 30. do you see that yeah so
um
am I
am I
is it correct that the 11 30 at the
beginning of this is referring to 11 30
pm
um yeah that would make sense
so so this is the same day that you were
notified that Mr Duff had injured his
finger correct
um according to this yes
and this was also the same day that Mr
Depp was was seen in the AER for his
finger correct
okay
um in the middle of the page here do you
see or in the middle of this entry do
you see where it says upon arrival back
to apartment patient discussed feelings
of anger and sadness about his
relationship patient was encouraged to
stay away from wife as the relationship
is toxic patient expressed verbal
understanding and why they needed to
separate you see that
um
do you have any recollection of this
conversation Beyond what's reflected in
the notes I do not
do you have any reason to doubt the
accuracy of what you documented in your
notes I do not
um do you recall
advising Mr Depp to stay away from this
herd
I don't recall anything other than
what's stated in my notes
do you recall ever having the view that
Mr Depp and misheard's relationship with
Thompson
yes
and what's the basis for that view
conversations
that he would share with me
um
what did Mr Depp share with you
I don't remember specifics just like
things we've reviewed in my notes that
he would be emotional and
that the relationship was causing him
stress
um
after Mr Depp injured his finger in
Australia do you recall him coming back
to LA
yeah I don't recall specifics but I know
we did return to La at some point
was Mr Depp's
hand bandaged at all
yes
and why was that
at one I mean beforehand we kept it
bandaged to keep it clean and then he
had surgery and it was bandaged after
the surgery
do you recall that Mr Duff had pins in
his finger
yes
um
do you recall Mr Depp reporting that his
finger was in pain
yes how would he report his pain to you
I have to review my notes for specifics
um well let's take a look at
the entry in your notes for March 23rd
2015 which
is on
pay
week
it starts on page
1735 and goes on to 736. yeah
um
actually before we turn to that one do
you see in the entry above for 320 215
do you see that entry yeah okay and you
see
um next to 20 the portion of the entry
that starts with 2015. you see in the
middle it says currently
five slash ten
yes do you know what that refers to
paying scale
okay and is that
um
how Mr Depp would report his pain to you
according to my notes
okay so now going to
um the entry for March 23rd
um first of all do you see the portion
of the entry that starts with 120.
yes is this uh 1 20 in the morning bam
according to this yes okay
um
patient states his wife is trying to
argue with him
I see I see that
and
again you have no reason to doubt the
accuracy of your note
correct
turning to the next page
do you see the portion of the note that
starts with 5 45.
yes and if the call to Loft correct
um what does that refer to
I don't know specifically loft is where
they were living
is that the Eastern Columbia building
and then the next two sections of this
note says 8 20 Torrid vowel and then at
14 45 the same thing do you see that
what is that referring to
in complete notes it would have been
tore it all in volume and then it
started
and uh do you have any recollection as
to why those medications would have been
administered
they were for his
pain
and then you see below that it says Fu
Thursday afternoon and Tuesday afternoon
skin graft bandage off week from Tuesday
pin off to been pin off in two weeks
um
what does this reflect
let me call
did Mr debb have us been graft on his
finger
he did
and I think you testified her you just
testified
um he had pins in his fingers as well
right
sorry I didn't hear that correct
um
so
at this time on March 23rd he had
bandages and a skin graft
and pins in his finger
according to this yes
and then
[Music]
do you see in the section that starts
with 20.
20 hundred
um
patient informed wife is coming to talk
to him and he became extremely anxious
you see that I do
you have any recollection of why Mr Depp
was anxious I do not
um
do you remember being present for a
fight with Mr debb between Mr Depp and
Miss heard
um shortly after Mr Depp returned from
Australia
I don't remember specifics
do you recall a fight when
Amber's sister Whitney was present
I don't recall
um
can we please pull up
um
document H please
give it 27.
um
now just for the record
um this is a document that has the base
number wh 106 through 109 and Miss Lloyd
you're not included on this
um but I just want to direct your
attention to the first text message here
um
it this is I can represent to you these
are text messages between Aaron Borum
and and Whitney heard
um and before I proceed do you know who
Whitney hurt is
have you met her before
how many occasions have you met with me
I don't recall
and what is Whitney's relation to miss
hard
sister
the first text message appears to be
from Aaron Borum and it says Debbie just
and it's on
um
14 it's at 1432 in military time at on
the date March 23 2015. do you see that
yes okay that says Debbie just told me
what is going on and to check with you
is Amber awake or fall asleep do you see
that yeah do you recall reaching out to
Aaron Borum
um on this date I do not
um
directing your attention down to
Whitney's
uh to three messages down from Whitney
um
or excuse me let's go up
um
do you see that Whitney responds to
Aaron she finally fell asleep
and then Aaron says thank goodness she
must be exhausted you want me to come to
the loft or is she safe and sound asleep
do you see that yeah okay and then
Whitney responds safe no she's not she
keeps saying she wants to kill herself
do you see that I do did you ever hear
Miss heard
um say that she wanted to kill herself
no okay
do these text messages combined with
your notes refresh your recollection
about an incident that occurred on March
23 2015.
I remember an incident but I don't
remember
the dates of it
uh what incident are you remembering
um there was an incident where Johnny
and Amber got into a fight at The Lofts
and what do you remember about that
um I was
staying next door at a hotel in security
had come to get me saying that they had
had an argument and Johnny wanted to go
back to 86.
so is that sorry is 86 um the sweet
serve property yes okay sorry continue
um
and so I went I went to The Lofts and I
remember that night Amber was already
leaving she was in the um
Lobby when we walked through and when
she saw that I was coming she came back
up to the apartment
and what happened when this hurricane
back up to the apartment
I don't remember
specifically what happened I remember
Johnny was sitting outside and we went
to leave and somehow we didn't end up
leaving
and why didn't you end up leaving I
don't remember
on
do you remember who else was in the
apartment
um I remember Travis one of the security
guards was there
anyone else that you can remember I
don't remember exactly who else was
there
is Travis Travis mcgivern correct
um
do you recall being misheard throw
anything at Mr death
I do not
do you remember Mr death throwing
anything at Miss hard
I don't recall
do you remember witnessing any physical
violence on that
I saw Johnny
push over one of Amber's clothing racks
no physical violence directed at it
correct okay
um
okay and then you
you said you didn't end up leaving the
apartment after that correct
at some point that night we left
and when you say we um who does that
include
myself Johnny and Travis
and where did you go
I don't remember
do you know where Amber what that
I don't know okay
but she didn't come with you
ladies and Gentlemen
let's go ahead and take our afternoon
recess for 15 minutes okay again don't
talk to anybody and don't uh don't do
any outside research okay all right
we'll see you in 15 minutes
foreign
45 then okay all right thank you
all right are we ready for the jury
yes okay
are we ready we're ready for the jury
thank you
all right thank you
all right if you want to continue with
the testimony thank you
um can we please go back to the nursing
note which are exhibit 23.
and specifically
um could we go to the entry for March
25th that starts on depth 1736 and goes
on to 1737.
um Miss Lloyd you see at the bottom here
where it says uh 325
yes okay okay and um if we could just go
to the next page
um you'd agree that this is a
continuation of that note correct
yes okay and you've seen under uh 1330
it says patient states pain is four out
of ten do you see that I do okay and
what does that reflect
um pain was being rated at a 4 out of 10
out of 10 out of 10.
um
and then directing your attention down
to the entry from March 26th
um
this is a note that you prepared yes
yes okay and just to
make sure I'm not sure in the past but
um the the prior two notes we looked at
those are also notes you prepared right
um
now if you why don't you take a moment
and read through this note and just let
me know when you're done
okay
um
now the beginning of the note starts at
1 45 do you see that and so again is
that 1 45 in the morning
and it says here RN called the patient's
home upon arrival patient and wife were
fighting in the garage do you see that I
do can you remember this incident I do
not
um it says when argument became heated
patient removed himself from situation
and had security drive him to another
home
you see that
um
I think you just testify you don't
remember witnessing this correct
I do not
um but you don't have any reason to
doubt the accuracy of what you wrote
down in your note correct I do not
um
had you seen Mr Dapper move himself from
fights before in this manner
yes
um could we please turn to the entry for
March 31st
which is on stage
uh depth 1740.
um Miss Floyd this is also a note you
prepared it is
um
do you see
um the portion that starts 130 patient
continues to co pain 10 10 which is
causing anxiety and insomnia can you see
that
what what does this mean plaintiff
continues to co pain 10 slash 10.
complaint of okay and
the 10 out of 10 is the the pain on the
scale that you referenced previously
correct correct
um
do you uh directing your attention down
to the portion that starts with 16 15.
um
it says at follow-up with surgeon
bandage was removed from skin graft
took a hundred percent there but there
was an infection under bolster finger
was drained pin was removed and
roasted in 1G was administered during
appointment did I read that correctly
I'm gonna have my pronunciation is
incorrect um
uh what
does this reflect that Mr Depp had the
bandage from his skin graft on his right
middle finger removed on this date
meaning removed at that time or removed
for good
uh removed at that time at that time
that's what that would mean
and the pin from his finger was also
removed according to this
um and when you say the bandage was
removed at that time
um
are you clarifying that because another
bandage was put on
I don't remember that's why I was
clarifying okay
um
you remember what type of bandages Mr
Depp had on his hand
time
I didn't hear you what type of bandage
yes
um I I don't remember specifics
was it a hard cast or a soft cast
soft okay was Mr Debb's hand mode I'm
sorry I don't recall if it was a cast
but I know the bandage was soft okay do
you recall whether Mr Depp could move
the hand that was bandage
and yes for a while he was his finger
was like splinted
okay can you grab anything with that
hand
I remember him pretending he had a claw
he could do this
or were certain fingers bound together
in the cast
I don't remember specifics
um
Mr Depp eventually uh returned to
Australia after
the time period we were just discussing
correct
correct and you returned with him
correct
and um
how long did you stay in Australia
on that
trip
I don't recall
I'd like to direct your attention to the
last page of this document all right
um
basically for July 1st do you see that
yes
um
please take a moment and read through
this and just let me know when you're
when you're done
I'm done okay great
from this is a note you prepared yes
and do you remember the events reflected
in this Village I do not
um directing your attention to the
portion that starts with 12 35.
do you see where it says RN received
text from patients assistants that the
arguments between patient and why are
continuing and orange have come to the
set to see patients did I read that
correctly
sorry I didn't hear your response
um
who is the assistant referred to here
you can recall I don't recall he had two
main assistance
and who were they
Stephen and Nathan
do you recall
both of them being in Australia
I don't recall they were both there
um
why did they why did you understand
break that
um
why did you understand that you were
being called to say
Jackson hearsay
I I don't recall at the time
um all right now directing your
attention to the last part of this note
that says 2100.
um
says here between shooting patient was
able to express his feeling to our end
he explained that his wife makes him
feel that he can never do anything right
and that they cannot have a conversation
without her blowing up
do you see that
um and I think you testified you don't
recall having this experience with Mr
Doug correct
[Music]
um
that goes on to say patient was given
positive reinforcement for expressing
his feelings
patient verbalized he knows it's best
for them to take a break from each other
when the fights start to escalate but
how she will follow him from room to
room when he tries to get away
do you see that
have you ever personally observed Mr
Duff try to get away from misheard and
her then following him
yes
well you don't recall him telling you in
this specific instance I do not
um
and again you don't have any reason to
doubt the accuracy of this note I do not
um
this appears to be the last note
reflected
in this document do you see that
um
and I think you said you don't recall
specifically when you stopped caring for
Mr death correct
um
I'm sorry what was the answer sorry
correct
sorry thank you
um
do you recall why you stopped providing
nursing services to Mr dead
I do not
um did you continue to work for Dr
Kipper after you stopped uh providing
nursing services to Mr Jeff yes
now I think you testified earlier you
don't recall the last time you saw Mr
debb
not for sure no
what's the last time that you remember
seeing him
I went to his
um one of his Hollywood vampire show out
here in the desert
was Mr Depp and Miss heard still in a
relationship when you saw Mr
not that I was aware of
um when was the last time you saw Miss
heard
I have no idea
what's the last time you remember seeing
her
yeah I honestly don't know
during
the time you were you were Mr Depp's
nurse
did you ever see Mr Depp physically
abused Miss hurt no
you had witnessed this would you have
documented and documented it in your
nursing notes
yes
did you ever see Mr Ducks throw anything
in this hurt
I do not recall ever seeing him throw
anything
do you
do you did you during the time you cared
for Mr Depp did you ever see Miss heard
physically abused Mr death
no
did you ever see Miss heard throw
anything at Mr death
I don't recall
in the time that you cared for Mr Depp
did he ever tell you that this herd was
physically abusive
I don't recall any conversations like
that
were you ever concerned for Mr Depp's
safety around this herd
were you ever called Over by Mr Depp
when he was in a fight with his heart
I remember if it was when a fight I
remember being called over after fights
and why to the extent you know why were
you being called over my role with
Johnny was medication or emotional
support
um how many times did you travel with Mr
death while he was under your chair
multiple but I wouldn't I don't know a
specific number
um did you ever witness Mr Depp and
misheard get in arguments while you were
traveling
yes
and what would Mr Depp do in those
circumstances
I don't remember specifics
other than the one time I mentioned on
the airplane
did Mr Depp ever book a separate room to
separate himself from misheard
I don't recall
have you ever witnessed Miss heard lose
her temper
I don't recall specifics
what do you recall generally
I can't recall
um
in the time you treated Mr Depp did you
ever suspect he was under the influence
of
um alcohol
I don't recall specific times being of
concern
do you recall any specific instances
when you were concerned he was under the
influence of drugs that had not been
prescribed by one of his Physicians
thank you
um
did Mr Depp ever tell you that someone
had taken his prescription drugs
I don't recall a conversation
uh could we pull up
a lot if it I please
stand by
and just for the record this is a
document bearing the faith member's
death
7804 through
7 8 40.
so the 28th
um Miss Floyd these are I'll represent
that these are text messages between you
and Mr deaf I think you 've seen some of
uh some portions of this document
um when you're answering Mr nadelhoff's
questions
um but I'd like to just direct your
attention specifically to messages
between you and Mr deaf on May 27 2015
which appears on page
um
seven eight four one and goes up through
to seven eight four three
Council was there an instruction
oh yes I'm sorry
um can you please go to
um
the page 7841
and we're going to be scrolling through
uh the pages after that
um
it's updating two pages
yep
see the text message that starts in row
that 320.
yes okay so I would like you to please
read through the text messages in row
320 through
337 which are
um from May 27 2015 and before you begin
um
I just want to confirm this number under
participants next to your name that's
your phone number
oh yeah but I was looking below I was
like no yes okay
um okay so if you could read through the
end the text messages reflected in rows
320 through 337 and then just let me
know when you're done
okay I'm done to 322.
foreign
are you done through 3 37 oh yeah yeah
all right
um do you recall this exchange with Mr
Depp I do not
uh do you have an understanding of what
you and Mr Depp are discussing
I mean just from what the text messages
says I can see what he was saying what
was Mr duck saying
that his um as needed medications were
missing
um
anything else about how they came to be
missing
I don't I already don't remember what
the above text dated
okay let's go to the text that's in row
33 oh three three
um and it says here saw them she wiped
me out of everything need Adderall in
the prns I don't like to be out of stuff
on the just in case kind of deal I can't
believe she's got the balls to Flat Out
steal my meds for her [ __ ]
debaucheries hard game after all she is
the sister X me did I read that right
objection here do you have any
understanding as to what Mr Duff is
referring to there
I do not
do you know who he's referring to when
he says she is the sister
I do not
sure how did miss her treat you when you
first started caring for Mr Beth
she was accepting
did that ever change in the time you
treated Mr Depp
I felt it did you felt that at some time
Miss herd's
um
demeanor towards you changed in the
correct
yes okay when when do you recall her
demeanor changing can't recall
specifically
how did her how did her treatment of you
change it wasn't so much her treatment
of me of me hearing that she didn't want
me around from other members
who did you hear that from
I I don't recall specific
it was from other staff people that we
worked with
did you
understand do you have any understanding
as to why she didn't want to be around
I do not
was misheard unfriendly towards you
no
did Miss heard ever get angry
at you in your presence
not that I recall
so just to be clear you're understanding
that misheards
um feelings towards you changed is based
off of what you heard from other people
correct yes
and your your understanding was that you
as you said she didn't want you around
correct
yes
Mr Depp was your Mr Depp was your
patient correct right and Amber Heard
was not your patient is that right
correct
you would you would classify before I
believe that you said one of your roles
for Mr death was providing him emotional
support that I recall that correctly
correct
that you didn't have that role for Amber
Heard correct
um one of the exhibits I saw it was
exhibit I believe Lloyd 22 there was a
reference to poly substance abuse what
is that
probably substance abuse is
used to determine the use of different
drugs and or alcohol
so it's abusing more than one drug or
alcohol is that right
that's what it's the term means yes
um
could we go to Hawaii 23. so this lawyer
would be the March 7th 2015 entries
okay
and you see the entry for 1300.
yes you wrote a patient was having a
hard time leaving the house so security
suggested
the MD and RN go to house to see
patients
upon arrival of the house patient was
sitting in car ready to leave
mdss patient's finger and we'll spend
more time with patient at the location
he's being moved to
you worth that I did
and that was based and you were with
that based off of information you were
provided
I I don't recall what that first
sentence is guarding or you don't have
any reason to question the accuracy of
the statement
I do not
um and then at 11 30 the the bottom
entry uh you would testify a bit to that
um
after the
highlighted portion it says MD offered
patient volume 10 milligrams I am to
help with this anxiety and anger but
patient refused
you wrote that I did okay and
you have no reason to question the
accuracy of that
I do not
was Mr Depp expressing any you were
called Mr death expressing any anger
um only what I see I referred to earlier
on that note the portion that was
highlighted
okay
um
then you were then the highlighting goes
um going into the next page patient was
talking about wanting to drink alcohol
but did not obtain any you wrote that I
did
and that was based off of what you saw
with Mr Depp
according to this yes
and there's no reason to question the
accuracy of that note
correct
and then at 3 8 15
145 you write a patient has been on
phone with his security guard that is
staying with his wife at their rented
house patient is discussing wanting to
go home to LA tomorrow and rehashing
night patients personal security guard
came to stay with patient RN will be
next door and instructed security to
call during the night if needed you
wrote that
um do you know what you meant by um
patient is discussing wanting to go home
to LA tomorrow and rehashing night
I don't I do not recall what that's
referring to
yeah I believe you testified way in the
beginning that um you are
you go to Dr Kipper as a patient is that
right
not going into details but how long have
you been his patient
since before I went to nursing the early
2000s okay and you consider Dr Kipper to
be a friend yes
when you were with Mr Depp in Australia
was he drinking at that time
I don't recall him drinking
do you recall that he was specifically
abstaining from drinking during that
time
I don't recall
did you ever see Miss heard drink in
front of Mr Depp while he was abstaining
from alcohol
yes
did you ever
um did he ever ask her not to do that to
your knowledge not to my knowledge
all right
your next Witness
your honor uh Mr duck calls Sean that
Sean
hey how do you spell the last name I'm
sorry
b-e-t-t b-e-t-t thank you thank you
oh
foreign
okay thank you ma'am thank you good
afternoon Mr Bat good afternoon
state your name for the record
Joshua Sean Bett
y Mr bet what is your occupation
I'm currently security with Johnny Depp
and uh your current employer is Mr death
that's correct
how long have you been in private
security
approximately just over 20 years
prior to working in private security
what were you doing professionally I was
with the Los Angeles County Sheriff's
Department
and how long were you with the LA County
Sheriff's Department
um just over 14 years
it was 14 years would you please
describe for the jury responsibilities
in each position you held with the LA
County Sheriff's Department yes I was
assigned a custody division where we
handled the intake and outtake of
inmates
then I was um assigned to a Patrol
Division where I was assigned to Crime
units where we were did calls for
service
proactive reactive arrests after that I
was assigned to gang details where we
focused and saturated in certain areas
within our district on getting shootings
and things of that nature then after
that I was assigned to gain units where
our performed search warrants and things
of that nature worked with homicide
worked with special enforcement bureaus
to combat a lot of the crime that was
taking place in our area
[Music]
did I did it come to a point where your
employment with the Los Angeles
sheriff's department came to an end it
did
and how did that come about
I was in a couple of uh really bad
traffic collisions and during the course
of Duties um the County of Los Angeles
issued a what they um call a medical
retirement or discharge and so I was
kind of forced out based on my injuries
and after you left the Los Angeles
sheriff's department what did you do
next
I was doing a some Private
Investigations and I also was doing
um security Estate Security at various
uh residents and offices and working
with different Executives on certain
details
and were you when you were doing State
security did you work with a certain
clientele
I did what type of clientele it ranged
from
CEOs VPS of Fortune 500 companies to
certain types of celebrities as well
how did you come to be employed by Mr
Depp
during the course of
um work in the State security and the
type of private security you come in
contact with a lot of other individuals
and security companies uh what we like
to call networking so when you network
with a lot of individuals they call you
from time to time to ask you if you're
available to work certain days weeks
events and things of that nature so I
was asked by an individual if I want to
work the estate of Mr Depp and I of
course said yes on a part-time basis at
the time
and where is Mr Dave Mr death's estate
it's in uh West Hollywood or it borders
West Hollywood in the city of L.A
and approximately what year was that
that was at the end of either 2006 into
the beginning of 2007 around that time
exclusively by Mr Depp I have I have
done other work uh over the years on a
part-time basis with other firms but
primarily within the last I'd say six to
eight years it's been with Mr Depp and
his family
and would you please subscribe for the
jury your General job responsibilities
when you first started working for Mr
Depp
it was mostly a State security so we um
controlled the you know people that
arrived at the estate we were there to
monitor the streets to make sure there
were no overzealous fans or Paparazzi
that would hop fences or would try to
sneak in bushes and take pictures of the
family and also entailed
taking the kids or the kid's mother to
school or shopping or out to dinner and
things of that nature
and when you say the kids do you mean Mr
death's children I do
and uh who was their mother Vanessa
Paredes
based on your observations Mr bet would
you please describe what it was like
working for Mr Depp in the beginning
when I first met him excuse rejection
what
the foundation I guess when are we
talking about is that what you asked I
could you print your microphone on I
just
vague Foundation also just relevance all
right what was it like working for
what's the relevance the relevances
you're on are just background just to
understand I also stay in the objection
we can move on okay
over the years Mr bet has your
responsibilities evolved over time as
you've provided protection for Mr Depp
and his family it has and how so
um I started to travel a little bit more
uh with them out of state and then
eventually out of the country and
worldwide
did your interactions with Mr Depp also
evolve from the beginning to now
they did I was around him uh quite a bit
uh when he was in town in the very
beginning of my employment with him
um he was doing a lot of movies he was
out of the state he was out of the
country a lot
um so once he was back in town if I
wasn't with his children
um taking him around to school and so
forth I would be around Mr Depp and
provide you know security for him when
he went out and about in public and so
forth
would you please describe for the jury
your general access to Mr Depp while
providing security for him
I had uh access to him at any given time
he had an open door policy I had access
to his residence the inside all the
rooms at any given time in the event
there was an emergency or anything like
that
and when traveling with Mr Depp was the
access the same it was I have access to
his hotel room again if there's an
emergency
um I have you know wherever he's at I
make sure and it's mandatory that I and
other security Personnel have access to
them
and would you please describe for the
jury your current job responsibilities
basically to provide security for him
and his well-being albeit if he's in a
hotel a residence or when he's out and
about in public
has your job title changed from the
beginning to now
yes I primarily now just
um work with Mr Depp not so much with
his children anymore so I guess you
could say for elect
for a term you know when we're in the
United States you know I'm kind of his
lead security guy
members of
there are and would you please name some
of those security members uh that would
be Malcolm Conley who primarily does
um his European
um uh security although he does come
from the States from time to time
um Leonard Damian Mark Gibbs
um Travis mcgivern
Starling Jenkins
Jerry judge
Jerry judge used to be his chief
security
individual he was with them
well over 20 years I believe and we lost
him a few years ago to cancer
over the course of your employment with
Mr debb have you seen him consume
alcohol
oh yeah
how frequently
it ranged sometimes I wouldn't see him
drink it all and there'd be other times
he you know would have a glass of wine
or two
and based on your observations how would
you describe Mr Debb's demeanor after
drinking alcohol
his demeanor is the same as if you were
talking to him
um I would joke around with some of the
other security Personnel he's you know
my terminology would be he's kind of too
cool for school he goes into that kind
of Jack Sparrow mode and he just you
know he's very likable you know whether
he drinks or he doesn't drink
based on your observations have you ever
seen Mr Depp appear intoxicated
I've seen them slightly intoxicated
and again based on your observations
what is Mr Depp's demeanor like when he
appears slightly intoxicated
it's the same as if he you know had a
glass of sparkling water I mean he's
just very low-key he's easy to get along
with and you know he just seems to me I
mean he handles alcohol a lot better
than I would
and over the course of your employment
with Mr Depp have you ever seen him
consume drugs
I haven't
are you generally aware that Mr debb has
used drugs over the years I am and how
are you aware of that
from him
do you know who Miss heard is
I do
who is misheard
she is Mr Depp's ex-spouse
when did you first meet Miss heard
it probably would have been uh
around 2000
11 12 maybe maybe around 2010 it was
some time ago
and how did you first meet her
she came over to his Hollywood uh estate
and would you please describe for the
jury some of your early interactions
with Miss heard
um she was very pleasant
um very easy along with I mean she was
almost as if she was a next door
neighbor just always had a smile to her
face and
um just um you know just you know no
issues at the time and you know I liked
her liked her a lot
in the early days of Mr Depp and Miss
heard's relationship did you have an
opportunity to observe them together
I did how frequently
in the early stages it was
kind of on a part-time basis because a
lot of times
um you know he was traveling or he was
out of town working on films and so
forth but when they were in La I saw
them quite frequently which could have
been the days that I worked which varied
um anywhere between four five six days a
week
and based on what you observed of them
together how would you describe Miss
heard's relationship with Mr Depp when
they first started seeing each other
Jackson Foundation all right foundation
your honor I believe I've laid the
foundation that he saw them frequently
together when they first started dating
sure how he would describe their
relationship this all right foundation
I'll sustain the objection next question
after Mr Depp and misheard started a
romantic relationship did you become
familiar with any of misheard's family
or friends I did
which ones
her sister
um Whitney heard
her good friend Raquel or rocky
Pennington
another friend IO tell it right
um Miss Pennington's uh boyfriend at the
time Josh Drew
and did you have an opportunity to
observe Mr Depp's interactions with Miss
heard's family and friends I did and how
would you generally describe their
interactions
um he was very open and warm to them he
you know offered them you know whatever
they needed they were constantly coming
around the estate
um you know eventually he led a couple
of them live in his penthouses downtown
for free he would let them a few of them
drive his nice
um Dodge Challenger in and around town
and take on trips
did you have an opportunity to observe
how misheard's friends and families
treated Mr Depp
I did
um they were obviously very pleasant to
him because you know I from observing
they were taking advantage of them so
they were being obviously extra nice to
the hand that feeds them and that's just
progressed over a period of time
it's hard to interact with you
all right what's the relevance
it's just background genre it's oh
sustain the objection and move on okay
foreign
were you ever present Mr Bett for any
conversations amongst Miss heard and her
friends
I was
uh can you describe any particular one
that stands out to you
Jackson your honor leading calls for
hearsay
all right
well to the extent your honor we're
offering misheard statements it's not
hearsay all right um if you can lay a
foundation to that let's see
do you recall any specific instances Mr
bet where um you heard Miss heard say
something to her friends
I do okay okay can you describe one of
those situations
yes
um the first one I was taking her from
um Mr Depp's property to her apartment
um in the South End of the city that I
believe Mr Depp was paying for
she was sitting next to me in the
vehicle she was talking to a girlfriend
or a friend where they were talking
about another male and she says to the
friend girlfriend whoever she was
talking to you know all men are idiots
you know you shouldn't trust that guy
and then she turned to me and she said
you know sorry Sean not you I didn't
mean that and I just Shrugged it off
like it's not a big deal
to remember approximately when that took
that conversation took place
I would say probably maybe
2012 or 13 perhaps perhaps even a little
bit sooner than that it was a long time
ago
and over the years of Miss herds and Mr
Dab's relationships did you have an
opportunity to observe how the
relationship evolved
I did and
well I'll just see what the next
question is thank you
um did you notice any changes in the
relationship between Mr Depp and
misheard
Nation relevance and leading
all right well I'll out if you could get
a timeline sitting there okay thank you
thank you your honor did you notice any
changes in the relationship between Mr
Depp and Miss heard after the initial
stages of them
beginning to engage in a romantic
relationship I did and would you please
describe those changes that you observed
well I noticed they went from being that
loving almost like high school couple
where they were very giddy towards each
other he was very happy she was very
happy to they started to argue they
started to argue periodically and then
the arguing started to progress more and
more and more and it was always taking
place because you know Miss heard would
start this argument
did you ever observe miss her drink
alcohol
I did how often
it just varied there would be you know
some days when I was working that I
would see her there would be other days
I didn't see her or she was out of town
working so it just really depended on
when she was around and when she was
around for the most part you know she
was drinking you know sometimes I'd see
a glass in her hand and sometimes I'd
see her you know have two glasses if I
was in the presence of her and Mr Depp
obviously
based on your observations did it ever
appear that misheard was intoxicated
there were times when I went into the
penthouse or we were at the Hollywood
estate and you know
based on my training experience in law
enforcement I could tell she was
slightly intoxicated excuse me see
that's kind of getting
into the realm of expert testimony he's
not
perhaps we can have him answer the
question without any exciting to any
experience in in law enforcement Mr bet
I'll just say an objection let's go to
the next question okay understood
do you recall observing any arguments
between Mr Depp and misheard
several
can you tell the jury about one that
comes to mind
uh there was an incident for example
um I just happen to be in the Floor of
their Penthouse which is on the top
floor of this building I was outside by
the pool area reading a book and when I
was walking back past their door I could
hear shouting I could hear her voice
shouting
um
you know at a very high pitch so I
didn't rush in right away or anything I
just kind of stood by the door
um he was you know speaking with her and
then the voices you know the shouting
act dissipated and then you know there
was music playing and then they started
talking so I kind of just uh stood by
the door briefly and then I went into
another section of the penthouse floor
do you recall approximately the time
frame of that argument
as far as the year or how long it lasted
I'm sorry thank you Mr bet thank
you could have been perhaps
2012 2013.
maybe a little thereafter
did Missouri ever
come about her relationship with
briefly
do you recall her saying anything
particular about her relationship with
Mr Duff there was a couple occasions
there was one occasion in which they had
an argument at his West Hollywood
address
um Johnny told me you know just take her
down downtown to the penthouse so she
can relax and cool off
um as we were driving downtown you know
she was crying this was at the point
when uh the the arguing was taking place
quite frequently and I was telling her I
go you know I said Amber you know this
can't continue you guys are either going
to kill each other you're going to be in
jail and you know with tears and
everything she says but I love him and I
I'm not going to lose him and I says but
you guys can't keep doing this so we
eventually got to the downtown
apartments you know she said thank you I
dropped her off
um and then I went back to the West
Hollywood address
what did you mean by
you know this can't continue when you
told Miss heard that the constant
arguing and bickering and so forth
because as I said it was slowly
progressing and
um you know it was just gonna turn out
bad eventually
I believe you testified earlier that you
observed many arguments between Mr death
and Miss heard do you recall anything
that Miss heard said to Mr Depp while
they were arguing
there was an incident because as I said
the arguing progressed over and over as
the years continued
um he would text me when I was working
saying you know
objection your honor calls for hearsay
all right I'll sustain that objection if
you wanna
Mr Bat if you could just focus on what
misheard you overheard Miss heard say
while observing arguments between Mr
Depp and misheard
I overheard her saying to him he's a fat
ass [ __ ] you Johnny and you too Sean uh
at one time when you know she went to
throw a water bottle or a plastic cup
down the stairs and it bounced kind of
in Johnny's Direction but I ended up
getting him and we you know got out of
there as soon as possible
did you ever see misheard throw anything
other than a water bottle
it was a water bottle or a coffee cup it
was something plastic
other than a water bottle or a plastic
cup did you ever see Miss heard throw
anything else
no other than what he told me when she
threw a broken bottle and sliced his
finger nice sure
sustain the objection the jury will
strike that that testimony please just
answer the question asked and when
there's objection do not speak okay I'm
sorry thank you
after observing several arguments
between Mr Depp and Miss heard
what happened next
uh as far as a time frame
um well as I said the arguing when it
would continue we would always you know
I'd put him in the car and we'd drive
back to his West Hollywood address
at which point it just depended on the
week or the day or the month you know
they would reconcile within hours or it
might take a day where he would stay
overnight at his West Hollywood address
and then you know I would take him back
the next day and you know they would
reconcile by you know talking and she
would have you know candles lit or you
know a bottle of wine open with glasses
and you know with within you know
certain evenings you know I'd get a text
message from her you know asking me to
go pick up dinner at local restaurants
they frequent
did you ever see any violence between
Miss heard and Mr Depp
no
other than the occasion when you saw
Miss heard throw something plastic in Mr
death's direction did you ever see Miss
heard hit Mr Depp
did you ever see any physical injuries
on Miss heard
I didn't
did you ever see any physical injuries
on misheard on occasions after Mr Depp
and misheard argued
here objection your honor Foundation
we're only a time frame to that
absolutely sure
on the occasions that you witnessed
misheard and Mr Depp argue after that
did you ever see any physical injuries
on misheard that's the same question
okay
all right move on okay
point during during Miss herds and Mr
Depp's relationship did you ever see any
injuries on misheard no
how about on Mr Depp yes
when did You observe injuries on Mr Depp
uh the first time would have been around
[Music]
um
[Music]
2014 I guess in which he had a
his finger was damaged from an incident
in Australia
do you know how Mr depth's finger was
damaged
injection Foundation Foundation
it's just background if he knows I won't
ask how sustain the objection unless he
was an Australian thought himself okay
okay
when else did you see injuries on Mr
Depp
I saw another injury around
um would have been March of 2015
. he had a swollen kind of cheekbone
eyelid
your honor if I may please pull up a
photograph exhibit number 146. I just to
the witness just for the witness that's
correct I'm sorry one four six yes thank
you
that's plaintiffs obviously one four six
Mr Bat do you recognize this photograph
I do and how do you recognize it
because I took that picture
[Music]
why did you take this photograph
well we needed it as evidence in case
um
miss her tried to make allegations uh
towards Mr Depp I was emphatic with him
telling him that's serious Mark and we
need to photograph it
I just moved to strike for foundation
I'll allow that answer but that's thank
you
and when did you take this photograph
it would have been around March of 2015.
your honor we ask that this photograph
please be
published to the jury and admitted into
evidence any objection 146 no you're on
it all right 146 in evidence and be
published to the jury thank you
Mr bet uh what does this Photograph show
it depicts a swollen upper left
cheekbone with uh
redness to it
on that specific day no
later in time did you ever notice any
other injuries on Mr Depp I did
can you please describe what you recall
it was around December of that same year
2015
um he
got into an argument with miss her and
she scratched him and he had injuries
sustained the objection only your
observations are what you saw yeah all
right thank you
Mr bet can you please describe the
injury that you saw on on Mr Depp uh yes
he had scratch marks
um
around his nose area
um I believe on one of the sides of his
face in the cheek area and then on his
forehead
65.
hi Mr Bat this is a three page
documents so if I can
have Mr Arnold Blair please scroll down
okay
okay thank you do you recognize these
photographs I do and how do you
recognize them because I took them
when did you take them
uh December mid-December 15th
and why did you take take these
photographs
I took them to show proof that he once
again had injuries sustained and an
altercation
your honor will move to publish these
photographs to the jury and for admins
yeah the objection to 65. no you're on
all right 65 in evidence and can be
published
and Mr bet would you please describe
what we're looking at here
uh the first picture
um there's a laceration on the left side
of his nose
it looks like the
left upper cheek has slight a slight
bruise to it
and then on his forehead right above
the ridge line just
almost to the center it looks like
there's a red scratch mark
above his left eye and to the right
do you see that
okay page two I see a um
scratch Mark a vertical scratch Mark
adjacent to his right ear
um
on the right side of his face
[Music]
same question for page three
[Music]
three uh there's a scratch mark on the
lower right portion of his chin there's
that same scratch mark on the center
left side of his nose and you could see
the frontal portion of that bruise
that's on the left side under his eye
were you surprised to see Mr Duff with
these injuries
leading
a stainless deleting
did you ever see any similar injuries on
misheard
none
did you see ever ever see any injuries
on misheard I didn't
start ever tell you she was being abused
by Mr Depp she didn't
did she ever ask you for help
no
did you ever see any evidence that
misheard was being abused by Mr Depp I
did
turning to April 21st 2016 Mr bats do
you remember anything about that day
uh yes that was the day or evening that
Ms heard was celebrating her birthday
with some friends
do you recall what birthday Miss heard
was celebrating I'm sorry do you recall
what birthday Miss heard was celebrating
I believe it was their 30th 29th or 30th
your honor if we may can we can we just
remove the exhibit oh yeah sorry
thank you
other than Miss heard's birthday
celebration that evening do you recall
anything else about April 21st 2016.
um he had a a meeting that afternoon
and uh which extended uh into the
evening and that was the as I said the
night of her birthday party uh where
they got into another argument and she
had uh struck him in the face objection
moved to strike your honor sir if you
didn't see it you can't testify to it
correct correct all right thank you
thank you for your honor uh the jury
will strike that answer thank you
foreign
were you with Mr Depp when he attended
uh the meeting that that you mentioned
earlier I was
okay and uh if you know who was that
meeting with
it was with his uh accountant
and who is Mr Depp's accountant
Ed White
and where did that meeting take place
it took place at his production his old
production office
um in the Los Angeles area
what happened after the meeting ended
uh when the meeting ended we drove to
his West Hollywood address which might
have been maybe five ten minutes away he
had to go inside the house and retrieve
something
um I don't know what it was we were only
there a short period of time and we were
kind of rushing because you know we had
been running late because it was a
birthday dinner and then we eventually
left there after and headed back down to
the penthouses downtown Los Angeles
and how would you describe Mr Depp's
demeanor after the meeting ended with Mr
White
um to me he looked fine he just you
could tell he was in a hurry and he was
you know telling me okay we gotta hurry
up and go to the house real quick before
we go downtown uh but other than that he
appeared fine to me
and uh based on your observations Mr bet
did Mr Depp appear to you to be
intoxicated he didn't
I believe you testified that after you
left the meeting you went to Mr Depp's
home his residence in West Hollywood and
then on to the Eastern Columbia building
is that correct that's correct what
happened after you arrived at the
penthouses for Miss heard's birthday
dinner
um we went upstairs and she was having a
dinner with her friends and one of the
penthouses I believe it was Penthouse
number five we entered uh the front door
to that Penthouse
um Amber stood up she walked towards Mr
debb she had a look of you know you
could tell she was upset the fact that
he was late you know Mr Depp apologized
to everybody apologized Amber and you
know told her you know sorry baby or
words to that effect for being late she
gave him a hug and a kiss and said you
know come sit down sugar
was that a nickname a common nickname is
heard used for Mr Depp yes she used to
call that quite frequently in front of
me
approximately what time did you arrive
to the Eastern Columbia building
it would have been somewhere between
maybe nine and ten o'clock
in the evening
do you know what time the birthday
dinner for Miss heard was scheduled to
start
I can't remember the exact time
do you recall how late you and Mr Depp
were to the birthday dinner
I knew we were running behind but as I
said I didn't know actually what time
the dinner was starting
and once you arrived at the penthouses
at the Eastern Columbia building did you
go inside
briefly I had a couple of Mr Depp's
computer bags and bags with me and I
just set them down on the corner and
then I exited thereafter
how long did you stay at the Eastern
Columbia building After exiting the
penthouse
I was probably there perhaps maybe
another hour or two and then I would
have been relieved by the night shift
security Personnel Travis mcgiver
did you happen to work the next day on
April 22
. I did
where did you start working on that day
on that day I started I drove to his
West Hollywood address because Mr
mcgivern had sent me a text message
stating they had an argument yeah I
shouldn't hearsay all right so staying
as the hearsay
why did you start your shift at the
sweetster property or Mr Depp's West
Hollywood property as opposed to the
Eastern Columbia building
because that's where Mr Depp was at the
time
do you recall anything specific about
that day April 22nd 2016.
um just he had told me they had a
sustain objection you cannot say what he
told you sir I'm sure you've testified
before correct yes thank you
did you see Mr Depp when you arrived to
the his West Hollywood home on April
22nd 2016. I did did you observe any
injuries on Mr Depp I didn't
in this time frame of April 2016 do you
recall Mr Duff's mother having any
health problems
yes
what do you recall about her health
problems
at that time she was very critical she
had been suffering from cancer for some
time a few years I believe and at that
stage
um she was slowly deteriorating
um so it was approximately a month
before she passed
do you recall when she passed away
I believe it was around May 20th
19th
and how did you learn that she had
passed away
Mr dead told me
and again based on your observations how
would you describe Mr Depp's demeanor
when he informed you that his mother had
passed away
well he just lost his mother so he was
you know uh you could tell he was you
know very sad and he was mourning and so
I just left him alone until he needed me
for whatever I had to do for him that
day
and to your knowledge Mr bet uh when was
the next time Mr Depp saw misheard
a month later sometime in May
I'm sorry was that a month after
first two thousand
projection leading sustain is the
leading
to your knowledge
after April 21st 2016 when did Mr Depp
next theme is heard
in my presence he would have seen her
May 21st
and was that after
Mr Dab's mother passed away
correct that would have been a day after
she passed
I have approximately 10 15 minutes left
I'll let you finish if that's okay with
the jury we'll finish Lisa direct okay
thank you that's fine
turning to May 21st 2016. um please tell
us what you remember about that day
um that day we were at his
um West Hollywood address
um
Jerry judge
his chief security guard was with me and
with us at the estate at the time
later on in that evening Mr Depp told us
that he wanted to go down and retrieve
some items from the penthouse
um and he also wanted to talk uh briefly
with Miss Hurst
all right do you want to talk to Mr
that's fine we'll leave at that next
question thank you
so you were working on May 21st is that
right I was okay
did you end up taking Mr Depp to the
penthouse's at Eastern Columbia building
I did and Mr judge uh was along with me
as well
and do you remember approximately what
time you arrived at the penthouses
it would have been sometime after
7 30
um maybe 7 45 7 15 around that time
frame and was that in the evening it was
did you enter the penthouses with uh Mr
Depp I did myself in uh Jerry judge and
Mr debb and what did you see when you
first entered the penthouse
uh when we first walked in on the center
island in the kitchen there were candles
lit on the table there was a couple wine
glasses that were empty and there was a
bottle of wine that was open
there was also music playing in the
background through the speakers that
were on the wall
did you see misheard when you first
entered the penthouse I didn't
what happened after you entered the
penthouses
uh after we entered the penthouses
um Jerry judge
um told Johnny that myself and
objection here all right I'll sustain
the objection all right next question
okay
did you stay inside the penthouse with
Mr judge and Mr Depp
no shortly thereafter Mr judge and I
exited the penthouse and stood outside
the door briefly
how long would you
estimate that you stood outside the door
of the penthouse
it would have been approximately maybe
10 minutes maybe a little bit more a
little bit less
and after standing outside the penthouse
for 10 minutes give or take where did
you go next
we walk down the hallway to Penthouse
number five Penthouse number five has
two doors there's a main entrance that
takes you into the living room
next to it around the corner it's a
continuation of the penthouse which is
like a storage area it also has
um it had a couch at the time and a TV
for uh the security Personnel so once we
were at the penthouses we could go in
there have lunch or dinner or watch a
little bit of TV and then
um you know whatever Mr debb or Miss
hurt would leave and I'd have to drive
or the other security Personnel we would
get a tax or they would come knock on
the door and we would leave
and when you first arrived to the
penthouses with Mr Depp based on your
observations did
was he drinking
he had had some glasses of wine at the
meeting he was at with his accountant
apologies Mr bad I'm I meant on May 21st
2016. oh I'm sorry I'm sorry did you
observe Mr Depp drinking any alcohol
that day
he might have had a glass of wine in the
car but as far as the entire day I
wouldn't have known how much he drank
did he appear intoxicated to you when he
arrived to the Eastern Columbia building
no
so you went to the storage area of the
of the penthouse area
how long were you there
uh we might have been there maybe
10 minutes five minutes
um we got uh something to drink and then
we exited that you know Penthouse I
described or that Penthouse storage area
and where did you go next
we walked down the hall towards
um Mr Depp's Penthouse which would have
been Penthouse number three
[Music]
we as we approached the door we could
hear the screaming and shouting from his
herd so I immediately opened up the door
and Mr judge and I ran in there
what do you remember Miss heard
screaming or shouting
it appears she was shouting profanities
so once Mr judge and I went through the
front door Mr debb would have been
standing directly in front of us maybe
about 20 feet because parallel to us
walking in or running in
there was a wall
it was the the way the the kitchen was
set up it was almost like an l-shape so
you walk in and then you'd have to make
a left so Mr Depp would have been
standing in front of us and he glanced
at us as soon as Mr judge and I rounded
the corner I saw Miss heard standing
next to her good friend Raquel
Pennington
and um
how was misheard standing where were her
hands
her hands would have been in this motion
once Mr judge and I rounded that corner
and she saw both Jerry and I she had
this look of surprise on her face and
then she looked at Mr debb and us and
she shouted out loud this is the last
time you do this to me
at which point Mr debb
looked at her and said what the hell are
you talking about
at that point Mr judge
tapped Mr Depp on the arm and told him
boss let's leave so we gathered uh there
was a couple of computer bags that was
right on a table and we exited the front
door to Penthouse number three
based on your observations did you see
did you have a clear view of Miss heard
I did did you have a clear view of her
face I did did you observe any injuries
on Miss hurt's face I didn't
did you see any redness
I didn't swelling
none
was matured holding her face
she wasn't
so what happened next
um we exited Penthouse number three and
we walked down the hallway
um right when we were getting close to
Penthouse number five door
um Mr debb says I need to get in here
and look for something so I opened up
the door for him we went inside and
that's when I saw Miss hurt's friend
brookel Pennington's boyfriend Josh Drew
and another unknown female that I had
never seen before and there was a small
dog kind of walking around
Mr Depp I believe he said get the [ __ ]
out of my apartment so Mr Drew nodded
his head and basically said okay the
female picked up the dog and they exited
the front door to that penthouse
what did Mr dab do next
I was walking around the kitchen area a
living room area he might have gone
upstairs briefly I can't remember I
don't know what he was looking for
um I didn't ask him Mr judge didn't ask
him uh eventually
um he didn't find whatever he was
looking for and we exited Penthouse
number three
and while Mr dupp was in Penthouse
number three Did You observe him cause
any damage
now
Did You observe him cause any damage to
any of the penthouses on May 21st 2016.
no
did you see Mr Depp become violent with
anyone while at the penthouse is on May
21st 2016.
I'll allow it that's fine
I didn't
Mr but have you ever seen Mr dutt become
violent with Miss heard
I haven't
thank you I have nothing for that all
right or you can stay right there sir
all right ladies and gentlemen that
concludes the testimony for today so uh
I'll release you we'll be back here at
10 A.M tomorrow please have a safe quiet
night please take care of yourself take
your vitamins we need you
um and we will see you uh in the morning
don't talk to anybody don't do the
outside research okay all right thank
you
all right
and Mr bet since you're still in the
middle of your testimony you cannot talk
to the attorneys or Mr Depp about your
testimony or about this case okay I
understand all right we'll see you
tomorrow 10 a.m okay thank you thank you
you're released all right anything else
for this evening
yes your honor yes
um wanted a point of clarification okay
okay sure go ahead um perhaps we would
you approach okay sure